the most important company for the Obama
energy plane as a company that no longer
exists today and it's in rock having
worked at Enron for 16 years and having
been kindle a speechwriter for the last
seven years and having been asked while
I was at the company to begin the
process of writing a history of the
company I wanted to come out with a
definitive version of events that showed
that the mainstream got it almost
exactly wrong that Enron was not the
result of capitalism proper or free
market capitalism it was a result of the
mixed economy or in particular political
capitalism where a business uses
government intervention lobbies for
government intervention shapes the
regulations for its own benefit whether
it's a regulation a subsidy or a
particular tax provision and Enron more
than any other company in the history of
the United States except for perhaps
some defense contractors and perhaps a
DM which has lived off ethanol subsidies
from the beginning was enabled by
special government favor Ken Lay was a
political entrepreneur or a wrench
seeker he was not a free-market
capitalist in any sense of the word
the mainstream should have blamed the
mixed economy rather than capitalism
proper and they didn't want to they
didn't want to delve that much one
example George W Bush who was governor
of Texas during in Ron's heyday and then
became president of the United States
they tried to blame Enron on him in the
Republican Party well George W Bush did
one thing that really helped Enron as
governor of Texas and that is a sign of
electric deregulation bill so-called
deregulation bill that had a provision
that required utilities electric
utilities in the state of Texas to buy a
certain percent of their electricity
from renewable energy which meant wind
power Enron had a subsidiary Enron wind
corporation and that provision aided
Enron more than anything else that
George W Bush did and george w bush's
decision at this point really launched
Texas as a leading wind energy state in
the whole country and it really sets a
precedent for what could be the obama
energy plan of mandating renewables
across the whole country
yeah unfortunately in our mixed economy
we have other kin light types one would
be t boone pickens who has a proposed
ten billion dollar wind power project
that he needs a lot of eminent domain
and a lot of government subsidy to bring
into the market Aubrey McClendon I'm
sorry Aubrey McClendon of Chesapeake
Energy is also working on the Pickens
plan with boone Pickens where they want
to use a lot of government intervention
to subsidize the conversion of
automobiles and trucks to compress
natural gas that would be very expensive
in the free market would have none of it
on the electric utility side jim rogers
ahead of duke one of the very largest
utilities in the country is a kindle a
protege he was my big boss my boss's
boss and he learned at the feet of Ken
Lay and when he left Enron to go into
the public utility sector he he became
CEO of a utility with a lot of coal
production he decided to team up with
the environmentalist and endorse cap and
trade a carbon rationing program really
the first utility executive to do so and
his thinking was if you're the first to
the party if you get your seat at the
table that you can shape these
regulations where it will help you of
course at the expense of your
competitors and consumers and he's
followed this strategy since the late
1980s and the latest is that Jim Rogers
plan for cap and trade was rejected by
the environmentalists and now Jim Rogers
wants to put a tax on carbon dioxide
which is obviously very bad for
consumers
energy policy under an Obama
administration will be very
interventionist the green jobs idea that
we can build these massive wind turbines
and solar panels and somehow this brings
us to prosperity is a it's a great myth
but it's probably something we're going
to see and it's going to be a real
challenge for the Democratic Party which
is supposedly the party of the middle
class this the small guy of the small
gal to reconcile high-cost unreliable
energy with the common good but my book
talks about in Ron's early investments
in solar power wind power all with
government favor and the obama energy
plan would be the in ron energy plan
writ large for the hope for the whole
country
of Enron's strategy of sustainable
energy centered around wind power solar
power and major changes in energy
efficiency the obama energy plans is
centered around the exact same thing
that our energy future has to move away
from fossil fuels toward renewables and
so if you look back and see what Enron
was doing the rationale all that comes
into play with the obama energy plan and
that's something that's going to be
popularized against obama's energy
strategy
as far as my background I first became
interested in libertarian ideas in high
school when I read the fountainhead by
Ayn Rand I went to college became very
interested in free market economics
particularly Austrian school economics
and after college I received an advanced
degree in economics and was working for
a bank in Houston and they asked me to
do an industry study they got me very
deep into oil and gas regulation from
that I wrote a book from the for the
Cato Institute called oil gas and
government the US experience and then
after that was over I decided to go into
the business world and got an invitation
to join Enron and I got to know Ken Lay
the PhD chairman there he had a PhD in
economics and I worked there for 16
years and for the last seven years I was
director of public policy analysis on
the corporate level and one of my main
job was writing speeches for Ken Lay so
I got to know lay very well so when the
company collapsed I was in a very good
position to write my own history of
events and it was about at that time
that I became interested in Iran and
objectivism again when i saw the
collapse of enron i realized this was
right out of a 9r and novel and so when
I was writing my writing capitalism at
work i have a whole chapter devoted to
Rand's ideas which to me explain the
kennel a paradox about how a person who
superficially at least had all this
talent in all this energy and all this
vision ended up in practice being a
total failure and I think the insights
of Objectivism a philosophical fraud
come into play here something else
interesting about ein r and as I went
through her books and studied her
personal life I realized that she was
party to the Enron of the Objectivist
libertarian
movement and that is the breakup of the
Nathaniel Branden Institute back in 1968
and I have an appendix in the book
called the Iran problem where I draw
analogies between that event which
ruptured the libertarian objectivists
movement thousands of people were
bewildered and stranded because of that
analogizing that too Enron and I think
there's a number of parallels